[Music]
Deion Sanders the hall of famer you can
seem eight and a half our pregame show
it's NFL gameday morning on Super Bowl
Sunday at 9:00 Eastern NFL gameday and
also prime as well coming up so Deion
Sanders joining us as well you're
looking clean I have a reputation to hoe
yeah you look you look nice
well here you go I know I was both at
home okay thank you sir you're a
professional professional I'm trying to
be like you when I grow up
really I'm just trying to figure out why
my seat is so low and you're so high I'm
like uh uh David Letterman what's up
with that David Letterman Tommy yes
right he was really good at it he would
be up so he was like y'all mean could
you be like this and I know why am I
doing this
yeah why are we here it's weird how it's
a power trip it owes to do that mm-hmm
but this wasn't by design trusty you
sure yeah I'm pretty much sure this
wasn't by design for me to be like a
power trip being above these guys sure
all right sure Dan okay we had a Michael
Irvin on yesterday he has nightmares
about one play one game what you're
involved in it why would he have
nightmare he said instead of all the
things he did
you know winning Super Bowls Hall of
Fame here's here's what Michael Irvin
had to say yesterday on the show
Dion admitted he interfered with you
well yeah a little an idiot appeared but
if the hill made it didn't get calls you
know what I mean it and it's all cool
it's just like you know woo well that's
right
but I feel her father's shoes that still
it was I'm telling some sister that
hurts me what that bothers me more than
anything I still have nightmares about
that place I should have made that place
somehow I should have gotten that play
made I still have nightmares about it
can we go back to the play the rest of
all Islip yep and regain in that
Lamborghini ran up on that Porsche
another thing would be I put my arm out
I didn't grab anything so where's the
interference
he said P I right there where he's I
didn't grab nothing it was the it was
that arm bar no I never grabbed let me
go around the room is it interference on
the other day look at the place I'm
holding tell me what did I grant well
nothing but I don't you can still
interfere without grabbing you can but
look slowly that nut that death never
about my climbing I put my hand out to
balance myself is that is it past it yes
or no passengers that is not pass
interference
okay as you're winking printing what a
coward uh back then maybe not at the
first today they would have phoned up
you're a good man you're a good man
phony - you're a good ma cheap love you
sure - I think if it happened today
we're not on this day we're talking
about then yeah I'm talking about 94
holy when the playmaker was here I said
P I when Dion's here I say hits clean
you man I'm gonna have to flag you there
let's fly get okay I can't take it it's
not like they were really in the game
right Dave hahahahaha we're being a
break supplement important what play
gives you nice sample you think back
over here career no nothing not give me
no nightmares no um what play I'm the
one play that define me or a regret or
regret no everything was everything
everything worked out just the way I'm
supposed to I still love the moment in
college when maybe it's Clemson can you
say up basically I'll see you in the
endzone I got me is going back I'm not
going to that but what what brought you
to the moment where you just felt like
you needed to tell Clemson you're taken
event but honestly man I know you're not
gonna believe this but I'm a real
spiritual guy and God showed me thanks
man it's been several times in my career
where I saw it before it happened like I
really saw it I saw it I can remember
going 90 Simone Atlanta and I told
Carmen policy and Dwight Clark on the
plane before I'm going to pick up a ball
I'm
go down this aisle and I'm gonna hide
step and I'm gonna look at him can it
happen I had already seen it before
you call it deja vu I call it God giving
you a glimpse of what is to come what's
the high-stepping and anyway a tribute
to family I am you now that was this in
the band at the morning band now that
was matter the heist ever since 74 you
know honestly it was it was just
something that happened is it it was
just something that we did in youth
playing youth football
part one or football in Fort Myers
Florida that was just something that we
did did anybody ever give you grief
about it like we thought about guys who
celebrate now and then you know did
anybody ever say something to you the
audition because I never tried to
belittle my opponent I never held a ball
back in someone's face I never spiked
the ball in someone's face I've never
spoken negatively about my opponents
never did none of that I just had a good
time doing what I did
Deion Sanders joining as part of NFL
Network's
8/9 powers of pregame coverage that's a
long time that is a long time the ocean
long time if if Julio Jones is office of
you Julio Jones is a grown man amongst
boys okay what do you do if he said use
the opposite you it's not what I do is
what who you'll do I'm the guy no I'm at
my mouth I never looked at the game that
weighted I'm so concerned about you you
had to be concerned about me no player
made you concerned Jerry Rice will keep
you up mat Gervin was great Chris Carr I
mean I played in the area of so many
Hall of Famers yeah but the guys that
really made you toss and turn a bit was
the guys that can score from anywhere
and not everyone has the ability to
score from anywhere on the field Jerry
had that innate ability so Julio is
going to adapt to you he's apt to
because the quarterback is concerned
because he knows if I get it I'm going
on step yeah I'm gonna dance and you got
to live with that for at least six days
on to the next game who did you not
that you a quarterback yeah I don't
think I've ever gotten Peyton Peyton got
me though you remember the play
yeah I was looking in the backfield they
was running down the hill station James
is running down he'll all game long and
and we called the naked hand and I miss
running looking so that second hand was
nothing in that hand and I understand my
turns around Marvin Harrison we ran a
posted it was sick and we went the
sidelines and the coach was going off on
the safety because it was a post in the
middle until I said no that's not him
that was me that was me that was my
fault
so the naked hand the naked hand there's
nothing in that hand
I still get great mileage out of the Bo
Jackson story you told when when he he
anointed you hey book everything go book
all night he saved you know called me
and Bo called me a month ago
first of all Bowl has that distinguished
boys like Reggie White you know when Bo
calls you know it's both you know it's
not like my phone said both but we have
each other's number and he called he say
you owe me I say what he what are you
talking about you owe me what do I owe
you
he said I just had to go get another
shoulder surgery from diving at your
ball in centerfield Yankee Stadium so
that's up for he went this I he started
the conversation that I old him yeah yes
Pauline we have an update on the bow
jacket remember last time you told us
about Jack's story we planted you and
you came up yeah you do and you said you
could beat him in the race yo I didn't
you said in your prime you you could
take Bo if my friend I can take Usain
Bolt right I the same folks not Bo I
mean butch Dan you energy projects
they've got it all burn for that tour
and both said I could beat Dion in a
race and I got 40 pounds on them but I'm
I don't know I don't think I said that
about both cuz I would never compare us
in a race so I don't know if I actually
said that but now in my prime I want to
lose you know I want to go out first of
all 35 and over I'll get right now
there's nobody ready but you know what
my son is right there I get up a run
every day and
we're looking for people to race
downtown like I was just I just went and
you can look at my Instagram I just went
asking people to race so excuse me sir
what you want to race I think because
I'm competitive and I've been looking
for people downtown just the race if
they win I'm going to give them a
thousand and twenty one dollars if they
don't I'm just gonna walk off are used
to walk off vanish are you the fastest
35 year old or older in the world not to
be a trike guy yes I'm not talking about
right guys that did run tracks any
qualified Olympics I'm somebody regular
man I'm a regular man I'm the fastest
regular man that's 35 and oh wait wait
wouldn't involve oh boy you guys throw
that in there too now not for long
though because I'm going to get you
taken care of in a couple weeks I'm
bringing my hair back really later like
her stuff like Jerry you're another
licker all you're gonna give her locker
yeah you're gonna get some Moss up huh
yep it's my hair but they're going to
sprinkle it this is breaking news right
here it is okay ESPN is gonna see if ESP
ins going to confirm this though yeah
Jenner's are called NFL Network will
confirm it
yeah Wow hair hair yeah but why I'm
going because I want to look like myself
honey I want to look like my son you
better athlete you bow bow like oh but
Michael Jordan but I can hit a baseball
man Magnum his face well why couldn't he
hit a baseball face hitting a bit you
can't learn how to hit a baseball when
you're grown man you gotta learn how to
hit a baseball when your kids sometimes
you can't do as a grown man that you
have to do as a kid you know it's just
something you just can't do could he
have been a great baseball player if
you're starting young I could be a good
golfer but I mean I don't do that I
don't do that no but does it hurt the
argument that Jordan is the best athlete
by the way he played baseball
Jordan was so good in one sport it leads
you to believe he's great in all sports
that's just that's when you know
you doing but now the best athlete I
would have to get that the bull Jack
these are Deion Sanders the Hall of
Famer joining us here as far as the game
the one question that has to be answered
would be what in your opinion this game
young witch quarterback is going to
produce the turnover if I said Matt Ryan
has no turnovers they'll win if Brady
has no turnovers they would win
someone's going to turn the ball over
and that's going to be the determining
factor of the game because when they're
so close you got to ride with the
quarterback like when a game is so close
closely and you don't know which way to
go you got to say okay now which
quarterback both teams is going to be
able to score one another you know that
yeah we know that we could break down
these matchups all but it comes down to
which quarterback is going to produce
that turnover they talk about Brady's
eyes and the defensive back that he can
look you away now I don't know exactly
what that means but you being a
defensive back of the quarterbacks eyes
doesn't mean that that means something
to a safety it don't mean nothing to a
cornerback because we're not you're not
even looking we're not looking in the
backfield we man okay we're looking at
if we focus on our focus but you don't
care like that was level would break why
would Brady make you nervous if he would
make you nervous what would it be about
him that would make you concerned he has
the innate ability to find the guy
that's open and he only needs a crease
he doesn't really need one step he's
going to deliver he's going to put the
ball where it needs to be placed and a
lot of quarterbacks a guy get a step on
you Nate on sin
Brady surveys to feel like a Eagle man
he's that good are you convinced Matt
Ryan's ready for this moment I pray so I
prayed that he is I wanted but I don't I
can't say I don't care who wins because
I do I do like Atlanta but I just want a
really good game yeah I want everybody
to be the best and I think Matt Ryan is
ready for the moment but this moment is
no joke I mean this moment was something
to behold for cam last year yep got the
MVP night before now you go into the big
guy
when would you thought it was gonna be
and it just starts to be an avalanche it
feels like in the Super Bowl when it
goes bad it could go really bad it goes
bad it goes bad we got an issue here
before I let you go
McLovin is terrific
Carissa Thompson at Fox you know who
prayed for chance a crush on me loving
my girl I don't believe it I don't know
no I know Christmas you know no no yeah
I swear to God no no I know Christmas
charissa like the chocolate bakery yeah
she's Willy won't be he stayed out of
wild five yeah you don't have the right
hand he needs to know what to wear
tomorrow and Krista Thompson come to sew
oh yeah I got good pop it now you can
you you don't know you don't have the
audacity um something thought-provoking
it looked like you cared something it
looked like you care just that's all you
need to get a beautiful woman like
Christmas well no no I mean she's not
she's not into the finances and all that
because she has all so she's not
enamoured by that I would dye the hair
black I would straight black oh yeah
yeah I would do that
okay um I would lose the hoodie yep that
would lose the city and maybe the tennis
shoe some loafers or something like that
you know just let her know that you're
you're making a difference maybe we'll
go shopping later today you know we're
not gonna do that there's only so much
the man yeah yeah I'm so much cash here
work miracles I need time with you eight
and a half hours of pregame risotto like
Godsey on how's the long thing I can't
do it I can't I can't do I'm gonna tune
in then you're gonna come back you want
trouble they go nuts survey you go to
watch everybody oh my god that's a long
time eight and a half hours no plan on
being there paid to have as I said okay
good let you know NFL gameday more yeah
you'll be outside racing people yeah I'm
gonna race somebody today in 40 is the
40-yard dash over there you too big
in the back you could be I didn't say
backwards I will go ray somebody right
now all right we'll take a break okay
and you got your shoes on I keep them
racing just like this Rich Eisen style
oh I like it yeah all right I'll pick
out somebody maybe one of the dentist
will ring could you you could beat him
running backwards good knee
um it depends it depends on who it is
now you could yes the Dan Patrick show
weekday morning on audience
[Music]